standing in front of this dazzling
russian church you will be amazed by its
colorful architecture and history the
church of the savior unspilled blood has
been a memorial a morgue and a warehouse
for potatoes
[Music]
known for the colorful onion-shaped
domes that dot the saint petersburg
skyline the church of the savior on
spilled blood was erected on the spot of
emperor alexander ii assassination in
1881.
inside the church
7500 square meters of mosaics an
abundance of italian marble and a
variety of russian precious stones
decorate the walls and ceilings
the construction of the church took 24
years costing over 4.6 million rubles
it was closed for services in the 1930s
when the bolsheviks went on an offensive
against religion
during the second world war the church
was used as a temporary morgue and after
the war it was used for vegetable
storage earning it the comical name
savior of potatoes this dazzling russian
church is home to some of europe's most
colorful architecture and history
[Music]
you